leanne what's going on so i'm a mom
working mom full time
uh three kids but two are school aged
my 11 year old son
is having an especially difficult time
yeah we're not going
back to school anytime soon so
my boy normally happy go lucky
kid very creative hilarious but
we're where he's having that tough time
he's trying to run away a couple times
two times he's tried to run away to get
away from it all is
how he put it and um he's
he's made mention of suicide so
my question is when do i say
that's it i need to seek the help of a
professional
um the second you get off this phone
call
okay okay um
this work from home this school from
home for kids
is um this is going to be a generational
trauma that we don't fully understand
for years and years and years and years
and years
it's devastating um kids are so hyper
co-regulated
that's just nerd speak for their hearts
beat and their eyes widen and their
faces move
based on the heartbeats and eye movement
and face movements and body movements of
other people in their area it's how they
interact with space it's how they
interact with themselves it's how their
brain regulates itself through other
people
and this has been an absolute
physiological and psychological
nightmare for them
and you throw on top of that mom the my
safe space
is being forced to have a dual role
right and i don't know that side of mom
i don't know work mom
i don't know teacher mom and you're
being forced into roles that you didn't
sign up for and you you're not equipped
to do right but then you feel guilty
because i'm mom i'm supposed to be able
to care for my son and then all of a
sudden you know what i mean it just
turns into a mess and i'm so
so sorry liam i hate that for you and i
hate that for your family hit that for
every kid in the country
um any time um
a kid mentioned suicide it stopped the
presses
we're seeing i read an article recently
um
talked about on the show um whereas a
kid as young as nine took his life in
in las vegas and we're seeing suicide
rates among children
really ratchet up they're just so so so
lonely
and they're losing those safe spaces
which has been home
and they're losing those what i call
uh accidental community where you just
that teacher winks at you in the hallway
or patchy on the shoulder they're
missing all that stuff and their bodies
are just in their hearts and minds are
going haywire
tell me what it's like homeschooling
your kid kid that you love a little boy
that you love
man it's to i mean i'm i'm barely
hanging on myself like
literally by the skin of my teeth just
and then you go to bed you gotta do it
again the next day
um walk me through what a day's like
so i get up i try to get up at 5 00 a.m
so i get a little bit of
un disturbed work time on my computer i
work at a house i meant
a hospital administration so it's
you know crazy at work as well i was
gonna say yeah that's a barrel of roses
this year too right right
oh right you're in california too just
exactly one
barrel of monkeys after another right
and i want to be a good team member help
my
you know the clinical folks that are
really putting the work in as well
so um so get them up about
so he likes to get up early so he can
also prepare for the day
and um then we jump right on the
computers and i'm bouncing between my
two kids
and my my work and um
it's it's chaos and then the grind after
they get off
the computers to get the work done
because it's
not just in class work it's once they
get off
you have this laundry list of
assignments that have to get done
by a certain hour you know nonsense
the pedagogy there is garbage
school administrators across the country
i'm calling you out it's trash dude
it's ridiculous because here's what's
happening and i'm not mad at you i'm so
frustrated with how some of these
schools are handling this
they are getting these reports of
learning decreases
and instead of doing what the science
says which is get these kids off these
screens and let them go walk around the
neighborhood and let them go play let
them go wrestle
they're doubling down on the other side
well after you get off you've got to do
more problems and more math and more
this
and we're embedding in these kids not
only this just
failure factory this disaster factory
but we're also embedding these kids
a distaste for learning and it's just a
gross mess i'm so sorry that that
you're pushing my buttons here i'm half
the country away from me
no don't be sorry it's man um
and so then your kids get done with
their homework and then what you're back
in it now you have to toggle back to mom
and after a frustrating exhausting day
yeah
quite then i turn the shuttle mom
because i'm trying to keep them active
thank god there's my daughter is doing
gymnastics i have him in an exercise
class because i just need them to move
their bodies
good for you and um you know when he
first tried to run
run away i called it i said screw it i
called his buddy's mom i said
can chris play because i need to get my
kid out of the house
we're risk our physical health for his
mental health
so he has some buddies in the
neighborhood that he'll ride bikes with
etc
hey that is that is mom of the year
right now good for you
good for you good for you
and i know that's a risk i know that's a
risk i'm gonna get my show canceled all
that stuff i don't care
no i'm good for you like there's a lot
of parents that are just
just you gotta draw the line somewhere i
mean
the kids are going crazy yeah so
um i won't i won't divulge too much
um my wife and i are still negotiating
not really negotiating we're still
working through um
which parts of my family life i disclose
for all these people on the show
and which parts that i keep to myself
what i will tell you is
i have heard the heartbreak firsthand
that you just
expressed okay and here's what i want to
not we haven't experienced the mental
health challenges and the suicide
challenges
but i have i've got a memory in my heart
that will be there forever
with an encounter of my son and
and weeping in a way that i've never
seen him weep before
and um just saying dad when is this
gonna stop
and um listening to him and my
wife and my daughter negotiate
homeschooling and work from home and all
those things
so here's what i want to give you
permission to do
at some point your roi on your work
world begins to diminish because
home world is hard right and not only
hard but it's
taking your core out from under you
right
um the core of who you are which is an
extraordinary mom are
you married you got somebody else there
helping out or is it just you my husband
um he has to go in so he's um
he's home till about ten o'clock and
then we don't see him again for the rest
of night
okay um so that might even be a good
thing there
your kids i i want to see them have more
direct
we'll get to school and get to school
dad and the kids are going for a walk
dad and the kids are setting up a wwe
wrestling tournament in the living room
and we're just going for it for a while
we will get to the classroom assignments
when we get to them
and at some point um
you guys have to double down on that
parent connection
and even saying i'm gonna be home school
mom
for this period of time and i'm going to
make you i want you to call me by
another name because i want to
have a moment when i can be your mommy
and right now i'm going to be your
teacher so call me miss
jo whatever dude but here's what i'm
trying to do set up some boundaries
between those roles because it's
really confusing for a kid and you as a
hospital administrator you are used to
toggling so
fast between all these different things
all the time right
and an 11 year old just sees mom and
sees mom working at a pace and saying
things to her clients and
to her co-workers like whoa i didn't
know she talked like that i didn't know
she knew what a tps report is and all
that stuff right
his mind's getting blown and his picture
of mom is morphing in front of him in a
way that his little 11 year old brain
can't
comprehend right now and you throw on
that how frustrated you are when he's
like i don't get the word problem and
you're like do the word problem right
all of that and so set up some
some boundaries like that and they can
be silly and fun like when i put on the
big yellow crown
that him and you know your other kid can
cut and paste and make a hat for you for
teacher
hat whatever but we're going to set up
some fun silly things that are going to
let them have some boundaries between
the roles and then
i can't believe i'm saying these things
i said it in a
in a speech the other day like
get in front of the tv and just hold
your kids right yeah
like just turn the stupid screens on i
hate screens i'm pub i'm i'm
overly loud about how much i hate them
but at some point you just gotta hold
your kids right
and sit down and color with them it's
worth
you know that's gonna heal your heart
it's gonna help heal their heart
whatever that looks like
we played zoom pictionary a couple of
nights ago with my gran
with their grandparents my parents and i
got to say this
shout out to my 70 year old mom who had
to act out quicksand
via zoom on a webcam
it did not end pretty and it was awesome
though
she went all in and then my dad who's 70
he had got sumo
wrestling as one of the charade cards
and that image will never
it burned a hole in my rods and cones in
my eyes like in my retina so all to say
is
figure out what those weird crazy fun
things you can do
and double down on them but let your
kids
know that you love and cherish them and
at this point
after a year of being home
man loving and cherishing letting those
kids know they've got value and letting
those kids know that they are still
tethered into you
is more important than whatever they're
going to pick up in social studies or
math class
at this point across the country it's so
uneven it's so
wonky some schools have never shut down
some schools have
not on back it's just going to be such
unequal
mess that i'm way more concerned
about the the connection and the love
and the peace and these kids hearts
all the way back to your original
question
11 year old runs away because he's
frustrated man
i'm i'm not gonna not every alarm is
gonna go off there i'm gonna talk to my
kid and make sure he knows he's loved
i'm gonna go for a walk with him those
kind of things
um i'm gonna let him ride bikes in the
neighborhood with his kids
my kid says i'm thinking about not being
here everything in my world stops work
can wait till later
friendships can wait till later all that
stops i'm calling a professional right
now
and i'm gonna do my best my best best to
get an
in-person meeting with that person
because just going on another zoom call
for your poor kid
um hopefully that they would let you do
that i don't know what the rules are
there
i know they are having some in-person
allowances here
in tennessee here we'll be thinking
about you and um
man you're doing the right thing set up
those boundaries set up those um
those moments of high high touch high
high physical contact
high high let them cook dinner those
things where they get to contribute
and be a part of the family household
where they get to see you being silly
where they get to
have work with mom for a minute whatever
those things are
let them feel a part of the home like
they've got value and let them ride
bikes with their friends man
and um geez louise i'm so so sorry
um yeah i'm sorry liam i wish i could
wrap this up and make it so great too
the second call in a row
that i want to just put a bow on this
one and it's hard because we're right in
the middle of a
massive massive trauma school
administrators
i know i know i'm being a jerk here man
because i know you too i've got close
friends all over the country school
administrators
pedagogically speaking you know this
eight hours for a ten-year-old in front
of a screen followed by three more hours
in front of a screen is not
learning stop come up with something
else and i know you got to get your test
scores i know that i know there's
funding on top of those two i know all
those things
figure it out there's too much science
out there there's too much there's too
much
and i also want to be safe i'm not
saying everyone should go back to
schools you all figure that out locally
i'm not getting in the middle of that
mess but i'm telling you pedagogically
speaking you know these kids
cut off at a certain point stop piling
it on
stop piling on these 11 year olds he's 9
year olds he's 14 year olds he's 17 year
olds
man let's let him remember this moment
not as the as the
make or break moment when i started
hating learning
when i started hating learning let's
give them project baseline i'm not going
to get into that dude
i'm going to make myself crazy